lla de nous sauver rien que ça
on est en train de vivre un des moments
les plus excitants de l'histoire
technologique de l'humanité le rythme
des avancées techniques des avancées
technologiques a atteint des sommets il
ya 20 ans on vivait absolument pas
pareil aujourd'hui on est habitué à
vivre avec nos smartphones avec un
ordinateur avec internet et c'est un peu
la grosse révolution la plus grosse
révolution du sort de l'humanité et en
même temps on vit une période un peu
tragique où on a détruit notre
écosystème on se rend compte que la
planète sur laquelle on vit on est en
train de la détruire
l'urgence climatique et de plus en plus
prise privées prises en compte par les
différentes personnes et du coup la
proposition un peu de naturel serait
dire pourquoi est-ce qu'on mettrait pas
au service de la résolution de l'urgence
climatique
l'enl attirail technologique qu'on
développe et qui est en train d'émerger
du coup je voulais aujourd'hui faire une
tribune pour présenter les usages un peu
les plus chouettes les âges pas assez
connu de l'intérieur artificielle et de
manière générale de des avancées
technologiques avant de commencer je me
suis quand même dit je vais aller
vérifier je vais taper artificielle
intelligence dans google et je vais la
regarder un peu ce que ce que me dit
google de manière agnostique et là j'ai
été encore une fois tellement frustré de
voir un peu l'état de la communication
sur le secteur dans lequel je travaille
voilà les trois premiers liens dans
google actualités quand je les ai tapé
artificial intelligence pour préparer à
la conférence d'aujourd'hui
le premier liha va détruire les emplois
encore une fois on nous bassine toujours
avec ça et quelque part c'est un peu le
propre du progrès technologique
c'est avoir des gains de productivité
pour remplacer là où l'humain n'est pas
performant je prends un exemple que
j'aime beaucoup qui est l'exemple de
l'invention du télégraphe au moment où
le telegraph a été inventé il ya une
espèce de panique dans le monde
journalistique
parce qu'avant on a envoyé des gens
couvrir à peu près tous qui revenait
pour communiquer de l'information et la
presse étaient principalement de
l'information et au moment où le
telegraph est arrivé en fait de
l'information est devenue super
accessible pour tout le monde et là du
coup grosse panique dans le monde
journalistique mon dieu on aura plus
d'emplois parce que l'information
devient accessible et en fait c'est pas
tout à fait ce qui s'est passé même
plutôt au contraire comme l'information
est devenue accessible les lecteurs ce
qu'ils ont demandé
du contenu c'est de la qualité c'est de
l'analyse c'est de l'interprétation est
en fait on a recentré à la fin les
journalistes sur la valeur ajoutée sur
ce que fait l'humain bien c'est à dire
comprendre expliqué détaillé et pas sûr
juste donné l'information et là c'est un
peu pareil
le premier exemple que j'ai fait dans ma
vie le premier à première chose que j'ai
fait dans la vie professionnelle
c'est j'ai écrit un moteur de détection
de fraude pour un site de e-commerce
ça marchait super bien et pourtant j'ai
pris des mois avant de réussir à le
mettre en proie dans conte avec les
équipes
pourquoi parce qu'il y avait une équipe
de fraude assez conséquente en face de
moi qui du coup n'était pas très
partante parce qu'il pensait qu'on
allait remplacer leur job par un
algorithme est en fait c'est pas tout à
fait ça la vérité la vérité c'est que
les cas qui sont simples les cas qui
sont évidemment des fraudes
on les passe automatiquement aux fraudes
les cas qui sont simples et qui sont
évidemment pas des fraudes
on envoie les commandes et ont ce qu'on
demande à l'équipe des fraudes qui a une
expertise métier qui a un cerveau humain
compétent et capable c'est d'aller
regarder le pourcentage un peu médian où
on ne sait pas très clair on a un peu de
doute éduquons les ressentent sur la
valeur ajoutée on leur enlève le morceau
pénible de leur travail qui est
répétitif est évident pour les
concentrer sur le moment où ils
apportent de la valeur
le deuxième lien s'était lié à ces un
énorme business et l'article seul outil
parler c'est pour les cards provider
pour les fabricants de puces pour les
gens qui aujourd'hui vendre de
l'informatique parce que mon la ruée
vers l'or les gens qui ont fait fortune
c'est pas ce qu'ils cherchaient de l'or
c'est les gens qui vendait des pelles et
là c'est un peu la même idée
aujourd'hui on est en train de vivre une
ruée vers l'or et les gens qui vont
faire fortune c'est les gens qui vendent
des processeurs
alors c'est vrai li a cédé en deux
business mais c'est aussi les conditions
d'émergence de nouveaux business parce
que en augmentant la productivité les
capacités de ciblage les capacités de
recommandation on peut transformer des
business qui n'existait pas qui était
pas rentable en des business comptable
j'y reviendrai assez largement tout à
l'heure parce que c'est la raison pour
laquelle je me suis engagé dans ce dans
ce domaine et le troisième lien
classique celui dont on nous bassine
tout le temps c'est lié à nous espionne
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui il ya des
machines qui savent ce qu'on fait c'est
pas complètement vrai moi ce qui
m'embête un peu qui est un peu vrai
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on est traqué dire
que les gens vont aller regarder nos
activités de manière générale sur
internet sur les réseaux sociaux
mais en fait il n'ya pas
sémantique ya pas de lien avec
l'individu et je suis je suis une
personne et ils ne savent pas qui je
suis vraiment c'est ce qu'ils voient
c'est bon c'est le prisme ne répèterait
petit de mon activité et l'ia est pas en
capacité de comprendre qui je suis ce
que je fais par contre elle est capable
de un peu me cibler un peu m'orienter
c'est vrai pas tant que ça finalement
j'étais quand même un peu surpris après
avoir fait ses ses trois recherches
parce que je m'attendais à ce que
forcément
forcément il y ait deux dans la
reconnaissance faciale et en fait ça y
est t'es pas et je vais en profiter ce
moment là pour mettre un peu d éléments
que conceptuelle sur l'ia on estime
aujourd'hui qu'il ya trois formes dia ou
trois niveaux d'hier le premier ce qu'on
appelle lui à faible lit à faible c'est
une machine qui est capable de
reproduire une opération que fait
l'homme à peu près aussi bien que
l'homme c'est ce qui aujourd'hui est
liée à l'échec de banque ou ce qui va
venir comparer deux photos de deux
personnes pour dire que c'est la même
personne mais encore une fois y'a pas
une notion de sémantique à vous tous si
je vous montre deux photos de la même
personne ont dit ah mais oui c'est la
même personne mais vous savez pas qui
est derrière vous savez pas forcément
quelques caisses qui est la personne la
caisse qu'elle est qu'est-ce qu'elle est
comme individu qu'est ce qu'elle aime la
deuxième t-il des médias c'est ce qu'on
appelle lui à forte il ya forte c'est
une machine qui égala de reproduire en
nombre conséquents d'opérations qui fait
l'humain très nettement mieux que
l'humain est là on l'a on en est
vraiment vraiment très loin est selon
vous avez sans doute entendu parler
skynet la révolution des machines c'est
ce qu'on appelle la générale général ou
généralisée c'est le moment où la
machine sera garde de reproduire
l'ensemble des informations
l'ensemble des opérations que font les
êtres humains bien mieux que les 3 2 les
autres humains et moon de noël est là
pour donner quelques ordres de grandeur
aujourd'hui on estime la puissance de
calcul d'un cerveau humain aux alentours
de 10 puissance 23 flop flop c'est
nombre d'opérations à virgule flottante
par minute on s'en fiche un peu de ce
que ça veut dire mais pour preuve de
grandeur les plus grosses machines qu'on
arrive à faire aujourd'hui que ce soit
les super computer du bm ou les réseaux
par l'amp le réseau minaj de 8,2 du
bitcoin c'est à peu près dix mille fois
moins que un cerveau humain et on estime
que pour simuler un cerveau humain il
faut au moins la puissance de calcul
d'un cerveau humain ce qui paraît assez
logique et c'est en hausse et c'est sans
doute très sous-estimées parce que enfin
c'est quand même une belle mécanique et
c'est pas sûr qu'on arrive à reproduire
même avec la même puissance de calcul
les bonnes opérations donc on a été très
loin et sans doute qu'on n'y arrivera
jamais parce qu'on est en train de dirt
et les bornes de la physique dans la
capacité à construire des machines de
plus en plus puissantes
bon je suis arrivé à s'essayer à des
plus populaires je me suis dit c'est le
moment de venir présenter de servir de
cette tribune vient présenter les âges
qui sont chouettes qui me tiennent à
coeur et qui sont cools avance à une
dernière petite parenthèse sur la
consommation carbone numérique
parce que si on dit que cet outil de
nous sauver en fait il ya une question
de un peu à quel coût parce que si en
fait on va on diminue de consommation
carbone où on améliore nos vies avec
l'usagé numérique
est ce que ça vaut vraiment le coup en
terme de consommation carbone
aujourd'hui on est à peu près 3% des
émissions de gaz à effet serre mondiales
qui sont produites par le numérique et
on estime que ce chiffre est à peu près
doublé dans les dix prochaines années
j'aimerais nuancer un peu ça parce que
ces enquêtes m'embête un peu et il faut
avoir un peu de recul dessus parce que
on ne mesure jamais ce que remplace le
numérique c'est à dire que numérique
aujourd'hui c'est des usages des
nouveaux usages mais aussi des usages
qu'on a remplacé par exemple il ya 5 %
de pluie en moins à la poste par an 5 %
pierre moi ça veut dire 20 mégas tonnes
de carbone qu'est ce que ça veut dire 20
mégas tonnes de carbone ça à peu près
dix mille français ça veut dire que la
poste par l'effacement de plis qu'on
envoie économise à peu près la
consommation carbone de 10 villes
français par an la même manière il ya à
peu près -3% d'impression presse écrite
par an parce que on va tous lire les
journaux sur nos téléphones
le prix mais la première chose que je
fais en me levant le matin c'est à dire
l'équipe sûrement ça sur mon smartphone
du coup je n'achète pas en format papier
et là encore une fois on vient pas
souvent mesuré dans les âges numérique
dans la consommation carbone d'animer la
dgi numérique les usages qu'ils
remplacent bref j'étais frustré quand
j'ai commencé ma recherche et quand j'ai
commencé à préparer les styles par le
fait qu'on ait toujours bassiner par ces
usages là et cette frustration est
double parce que moi je connais pas mal
de d'usagé longtemps pour finale du
secteur que j'avais envie de parler qui
sont passés public et que je vais
essayer de vous présenter un peu
aujourd'hui mais du
il ya des usages souhaite il ya des
choses on n'en parle pas assez pour
commencer il ya une initiative de l'onu
qui s'appelle et eye for god qui est un
groupe de travail international avec des
institutionnels des gouvernants des
gouvernements des industries des
chercheurs qui s'est donné pour mission
de trouver comment est-ce que
l'intérieur l'intelligence artificielle
peut venir aider à répondre aux
objectifs de développement durable de
l'onu l'onu a défini dit cet objectif
développement durable chacun d'entre eux
afin qu'ils vous sont sur la santé qui
sont sur le climat qui sont sur
l'énergie qui sont sur la pauvreté et
sur chacun d'entre eux en fait on peut
mobiliser des outils dia pour être plus
efficace et plus rapide trouver plus
facilement comment est ce qu'on peut
améliorer notre vie où économiser du
carbone notamment cet exemple là qui est
l'exemple sur la détection de
déforestation on a envoyé des dizaines
de satellites en orbite autour de la
terre qui prennent des photos quasi
quotidiennement et avec ces photos là on
peut venir détecter les zones faut
rester donc les zones sur lesquelles et
des arbres et comparer leur évolution
dans le temps et du coup ça se permet de
pointer du doigt les endroits où il y
avait des arbres et du jour au lendemain
il y en a plus et leur le gros enjeu la
déforestation aujourd'hui c'est les
coupes sauvages
donc si on arrive à pointer du doigt les
endroits où les arbres les arbres sont
en train de disparaître à un rythme très
rapide parce que c'est pas forcément des
zones faciles d'accès dans lesquels on
peut aller vérifier tous les jours si
les arbitres sont toujours mais si on
arrive à pointer les endroits où les
arbres disparaissent dans ce cas là ce
qu'on peut faire après c'est déjà à
c'est là qu'il faut les regarder c'est
là où il se passe quelque chose
et du coup on voyait des parents de la
police sur place pour aller constater le
plus vite possible et lutter contre la
déforestation sauvage
un autre exemple dans deux sujets qui
est porté par cette initiative de l'onu
un sujet sur l'impact des tempêtes
quand on contient une tempête quelque
part on doit décider de l'aide
humanitaire qu'on en voit à quelle
vitesse à quel volume et du coup la
comparaison des images satellites permet
de mesurer un premier impact des dégâts
et donc de décider de la l'urgence de
l'intervention et des volumes de
l'intervention la raison pour laquelle
je me suis engagé dans ce secteur de
l'ia est la raison pour laquelle j'y
reste
c'est un peu ce que ce que je fais tous
les jours je vais vous parler un peu de
de la boîte que j'ai cofondé qu'est ce
qu'on fait et qu'est ce qu'on s'est dit
on s'est dit que on pouvait transformer
en opportunités business des marchés qui
étaient liées à la transition écologique
notamment les marchés autour des
économies d énergies renouvelables en
fait aujourd'hui le solaire c'est
rentable il ya à peu près 40% des
toitures de france qui sont rentables
d'un point du solaire mais les gens ne
le savent pas les gens le font pas les
gens ont peu envie de chercher je sais
pas moi mon toit s'il a orienté à 12
degrés à 30 degrés à 40 degrés par
rapport au nord si la pompe ses 30 33
degrés je sais pas complètement où est
placé ma cheminée ou est-ce que je peux
poser bonne solaire et comme je sais pas
et que j'ai l'impression que c'est
compliqué de savoir en fait je ne me
pose même pas la question et je vis
peut-être avec la plus belle toiture de
france au dessus de moi sans le savoir
et de l'autre côté les coûts de
prospection et les coûts de conversion
des opérateurs qui pose des panneaux
solaires sont aujourd'hui très fort
parce que justement difficile d'aller
expliquer aux gens d'aller convaincre
les gens qu'ils ont un potentiel solaire
du coup qu'est ce que qu'est ce qu'on a
fait qu'est ce qu'on se dit on se dit si
on arrive à savoir de manière
systématique sur tous les bâtiments de
france
le potentiel solaire dépens de voitures
dans ce cas là on peut venir réduire ses
coûts d'acquisition et donc transformée
en une énorme opportunité business le
déploiement de panneaux solaires et
quand les nombreuses opportunités
business le marché s'en saisit et ça va
très vite
du coup on va les reconstruire sur
l'image des autres résolutions la la
projection 3d des bâtiments
on va aller détecter les éléments qui
sont sous les toitures pour à la fin
venir déduire la surface utile le nombre
de panneaux qu'on peut poser et in fine
et le potentiel exact de la centrale
composée sur la toiture et ça assez cool
un autre exemple
l'efficace innergetic c'est bien
produire de l'énergie verte
mais la meilleure énergie celles qui
consomment le moins de carbone c'est
quand même celle qu'on ne consomme pas
et on a un parc bâtimentaire en france
assez vieux pas très efficace et en même
temps on a plein de manières de le
rénover avec des incitations publiques
et et ou avec simplement une rentabilité
économique sur les travaux et c'est un
peu le même le même constat que sur le
solaire moi je sais pas trop que
l'opération je peux faire dans la maison
je sais pas trop
en fait si jamais je change de
menuiserie quel va être l'impact sur ma
facture électrique
je sais pas trop si c'est vraiment
rentable je sais même pas si je vais
rester très longtemps dans ma maison
du coup je me pose pas la question et je
monte le chauffage pas forcément un très
bon réflexe et la même manière si on
arrive à avoir de manière systématique
la vétusté des bâtiments le type 2002
menuiserie les surfaces vitrées les
matériaux de construction les types de
toitures est ce que les combes sont
perdus ou aménagés
si on vient extraire cette information
d'imagerie de sources diverses de
l'ensemble des dépôts qui a été réalisée
par l'ademe
on peut venir pointer du doigt les
endroits où en termes de rentabilité
les travaux sont les plus courts où la
rentabilité la plaie la plus rapide et
donc transformer en opportunités
business un enjeu central de la
transition écologique
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
li a de nous sauver ça veut dire
effectivement trouvé comment remplir des
éléments autour de la consommation
carbone des énergies renouvelables il ya
d'autres usages qui sont pas assez
public et notamment celui là dont je
veux particulièrement vous parle et qui
sont les usages de la 2nde artificielle
dans la santé l'exemple là c'est un
exemple qui a été développé par une
équipe de chercheurs français sur la
détection du cancer du sein
et quand on booste un radiologue avec
des algues odiah on augmente environs de
10% le score de détection et on diminue
de quasiment la moitié du temps le temps
de diagnostic pourquoi pas parce que la
machine est plus forte que le radiologue
et parce que le radiologue à venir voir
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de radios
dans la journée et si la tumeur est tout
petit
ça peut lui passer sous l'oeil de
manière générale les algues ont fait
aujourd'hui ne sont pas plus performants
que les humains ils se fatiguent pas par
contre ils ont toujours le même rythme
toujours la même précision et du coup si
on arrive à détecter plus tôt
plus vite plus efficacement avec plus de
certitudes les différentes maladies
on va très considérablement amélioré nos
vies j'en profite pour vous parler d'une
chose sublime d'une des plus belles
choses dans la santé qui existent dont
absolument personne seule salle a
entendu parler je pense
qui est le s dadaab en france on a une
chance c'est que on a un régime de
sécurité sociale
depuis plusieurs dizaines d'années qui
concerne tout le monde
du coup on a des historiques de
prescription de maladie de consultation
chez le médecin
2 40 à 70 millions de français à titre
de comparaison les plus grosses
mutuelles américaine c'est à peu près 20
me en personne mais biaisé parce qu aux
etats unis
la santé c'est les riches en france on a
tout le monde à la sécu et le fdf s'est
du coup initiatives pour venir mettre
tout donner ensemble pour permettre à la
recherche allait trouver des choses dans
ces données et le prg est la première
chose qu'ils ont faite pour ont prouvé
la valeur s'ils sont allés regarder
médiator et devinez quoi
dans les données on aurait pu trouver
avant que le médiator tuer des gens et
ça c'est quand même plutôt rassurant de
se dire qu'on est capable de mettre en
place des méthodes qui vont nous
permettre de sensiblement améliorer nos
vies améliorer les médicaments qu'on
prend et de manière générale améliorer
notre santé
je vais conclure sur une petite
métaphore pour vous en fait il ya
aujourd'hui c'est un outil est comme
tous les outils c'est dans les mains de
la personne qu'ils utilisent qu'il prend
son sens à un couteau ça peut servir à
cuisiner ou ça me servira pour garder
son voisin c'est qui et c'est celui qui
le manipule qui décide et je sais pas
vous mais moi je pense qu'on serait
vachement mieux à table
[Applaudissements]